okay so let's now step a little bit away
from the specific results in the Senate
and in the house yesterday and think
about what this means for the future of
political movements including the
progressive movement which is the one I
care about normally it is a great time
for the opposition party the party not
in the white house to make progress when
you have a midterm after a presidential
election Trump and Republicans winning
in 2016 2018 just simply speaking
historically at the base level was
supposed to be it was expected to be a
good midterm for Democrats however the
Senate was stacked against Democrats and
what I mean by that is you that you had
mostly Democrats defending seats and
Republicans not you had a lot of
Republican Senate seats that were just
not up this year so we already did the
detailed results but Dems won the house
lost the Senate and did gain control of
some new governorships which I'll
mention momentarily I am going to need
to talk some sense here to people on
both sides of this so-called blue wave
first of all on paper it really wasn't a
bad night for Democrats I know that for
a lot of people and I've been seeing the
tweets and the emails it didn't really
feel like it was a huge blue wave but
you've got to understand that the degree
to which it was stacked against
Democrats in the Senate Democrats with
way more seats to defend because
Republicans had 42 seats they almost had
a majority 42 out of 50 that weren't
even up for re-election they were
totally impervious to the blue wave
since they're simply not up for
re-election so yes Democrats were at a
disadvantage they've lost so far two
seats net in the Senate it might end up
being three or four we will see but
Democrats did lose some key races that
they should have been able to hold I
mentioned the Heidi Heitkamp disaster I
get it it's the Dakotas but it shouldn't
have been as lopsided as it was Claire
McCaskill another example I get it it's
not the most blue state Missouri but yet
another race that I believe was bungled
so that is extraordinarily concerning in
the House Democrats took control which
is great
barely though they needed 25 seats in
terms of a net gain they got depending
on where it'll be when when it's all
said and done is it 28 is it somewhere
in the low 30s it's not totally clear
the results in Florida were an absolute
disaster Andrew Gilliam losing there for
governor and Bill Nelson losing his seat
to Rick Scott in the Senate Florida
really big disaster for Democrats for
governorships it actually overall was a
really good night Democrats gained seven
governorships yesterday a net gain of
seven and Republicans had understandably
obviously a net loss of seven seats
that being said Stacey Abrams in Georgia
lost by just one point nine percent in
Georgia and there was voter suppression
there it's not actually clear to me that
she lost I got a couple calls yesterday
from people saying David should beta or
orc contest the results in Texas I don't
think so I don't know that that that's
that beta or orc lost because of foul
play
in Georgia however where you had the guy
running the election Secretary of State
Brian Kemp also running as the
Republican candidate for governor and
you had deregistration voter purges
limited voting hours closed polling
places and in the end it's that tight I
do think that that's one that needs to
be looked into other governorships that
went the way of Democrats Maine is a
good one
Michigan is interesting Wisconsin is
absolutely huge where Scott Walker was
defeated the guy is disgusting and it is
so great to see him kicked out Illinois
Democrats took over the governorship
Kansas where nightmarish Kris Kobach was
defeated and we'll talk about that a
little more New Mexico and Nevada saw
governorships
turn blue and to me this is one of the
biggest wins from last night taking over
the house is very important
but taking over seven governorships is
so important because this is now seven
more states that could decide to follow
the Paris climate guidelines even if
Donald Trump calls the United States out
of that agreement at the national level
this is seven more states that can
legalize marijuana as some states did
and restore voting rights to felons as
some states did or protect workers
rights which Scott Walker was not doing
in Wisconsin quite the opposite so that
is really really big and then the other
good news from yesterday is that if you
look at some specific states you see
that trumpism destroyed them and I want
to go back to Kansas the very red state
of Kansas where Donald Trump defeated
Hillary Clinton by 20 points in 2016 56
to 36 they have a Democrat who is going
to be governor defeating Trump crony
Kris Kobach Democrats in Kansas also
took one of four House seats from an
incumbent Republican and the person who
took it is Cherise David's which is huge
so in Kansas we've really seen how
bringing in this cut taxes and defund
social programs Sam Brownback
right-winger ISM trumpism I don't know
what name you want to assign to it it
led to a definitive leftward move for
Kansas that is really great news and
then also good news are the ballot
initiatives Florida banned offshore
drilling and banned indoor vaping they
restored voting rights for felons
Michigan legalized marijuana by popular
vote they will be the tenth state to
legalize marijuana that's a clear trend
nationally and it's of course going to
continue the momentum continues to build
so listen the big picture is Democrats
took the house they didn't lose that
much in the Senate given how the races
favored Republicans they gained seven
governorships and a bunch of different
progressive ballot initiatives were
passed we won the popular vote in Senate
races by 12 million votes if you
count for two Democrats running in
California it's more like nine and a
half million votes and won the popular
vote overall if you look at the popular
vote across everything that happened
yesterday at the net you know Governor's
House and Senate Democrats won the
popular vote by about eight percentage
points that's a blow out okay in
American politics that is a blow out by
any standard so Republicans do need to
be very worried there's all the positive
stuff okay that that we're getting out
of the way but here's where it starts to
get very very ugly
first of all does taking over the house
and plus seven governors do a damn thing
about turning around the corporate
takeover
of our political system and our economy
for the last 40 years the answer is it
doesn't do a thing and it's not fair to
expect that you would change that with
one election and I know that we can say
well there have been some further
leftists that won in the house AOC in
New York and some others that's fine but
only if they're able to achieve change
is that going to be a success point so
number one when I see the most
destructive and ignorant president in
decades single-handedly destroying
important geopolitical alliances around
the world making the United States look
like a joke insulting everyone making
economic policy with the total lack of
understanding of the consequences of
that policy and Democrats barely take
over the house I'm not just blaming
voters I'm not just blaming the
Democratic Party but we've got to get it
together okay if you care about what's
going on you have to vote and I know
voter turnout was up I know that it was
but it's got to be up more because
otherwise we're getting crushed in 2020
okay if there was ever a time to vote
wasn't it yesterday and meanwhile it's
great that Democrats took over the house
and gained seven seats in terms of
governor's but there is still no
cohesive Democratic strategy there is
this jumping
back and forth between playing
Republican light and being more
progressive being the sane centrist and
being Republican light in this constant
revolving door and most importantly
because it's okay to run races
differently based on where you're
running that's not the issue the issue
is that Democrats big-picture with
exceptions are not speaking to voters in
a way that truly resonates in terms of
why shouldn't they be afraid of losing
their status perceived or real if they
support Democrats that was one of the
top motivating factors for people voting
for Donald Trump the fear of losing the
status they either perceive they have
actually have or think maybe they would
have at some point in the future I'm not
saying that Democrats need to run the
exact way that Republicans run because
then we're just Republicans that's not
the point I'm making but if so many
people you have the right policies
within a reasonable sort of Overton
Window if you are a Democrat on many
issues but the voters aren't
understanding that and that's a
communication issue fundamentally and
then also they ran a lot of crappy
campaigns how can the Democratic Party
expect to win when this is what they're
able to do after two years of Trump and
some of the worst governance that we've
ever seen I am not one to defend Michael
a vanadis political approach I have my
problems with them but the one area
where I do agree with avenatti is that
he says we actually need to fight and
that doesn't mean compromise our
principles it doesn't mean do things
that we find immoral but Trump will
crush us in 2020 if we continue the
waterfalls and Ginger Snaps approach
that too many but not all Democrats take
you can't be Republican light you can't
pretend that you don't need to play the
game period and if you are disappointed
and you should be to some degree even
though there were victories last night
we have a new project we have two years
now where the goal is clear take over
the white house take over the Senate
expand control of the house and get a
majority in terms of governorships and
I'm going to be talking about that
shortly today's program brought to you
in part by Blink accom slash Pakman
blinka is a great service that i use all
the time what they do is they take
thousands of the most popular nonfiction
books including the newest bestsellers
they condense them into 15-minute
audiobooks that you can listen to and
you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink Asst I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book BS
jobs by David Graeber which I listened
to on blinka they're constantly adding
new books to the platform you will never
run out of fascinating and critically
acclaimed books to enjoy and our
audience can get a seven day free trial
by going to blink accom slash Pakman if
you're watching on YouTube I'm putting a
link in the video description and after
the free trial if you'd like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/p a que mas